in the last video we talked about
survivability and what you should focus
on if you want to stay alive the nomads
build excels at keeping you alive the
downside is that it doesn't really give
you too much in the way of extra damage
using you the skill power or firearms in
this video we'll cover skill power
builds these are so much fun and you can
get some crazy damage or utility out of
your skills running solo you can make it
further and with a team you can really
put out some good damage or assist in
providing your team some massive damage
buffs or defensive end healing skills
the last video showed a build that would
have provided some support for when
things went wrong particularly useful
when learning the game mechanics and how
to react in crazy situations this build
isn't quite so forgiving for the purpose
of this video we'll be talking about
running this as a skill power damage
build but the same direction and tips
can be used towards support builds - as
a solo player you can use your skills to
not only deal the damage but also take a
lot of the incoming fire that would
otherwise be dealt to yourself so even
though you'll have minimum toughness you
build to stick right back doing damage
from a distance with any build video I
post up you should be using these as a
guide only the intention is for you to
use them as a starting point and then
adapt them to your style of play I'll do
my best to show a few different options
within the builds but you'll need to try
these out and make the choice for
yourself as per usual I'll be keeping
this as short and concise as possible at
the end I'll have a couple of cheat
sheets that will sum up the builds
covered in this video please let me know
in the comments if I can provide a
little more detail on anything
the seat will focus this video around
will be the technicians Authority sit
this is the original skill build set
released way back in 1.1 but a lot of
what we cover here can also be applied
to the reclaimer set and even the fire
is set to a certain extent the tactician
set focuses on skill haste and
maximizing skill power and this pretty
much sums up exactly what we're going to
try and achieve with each piece in this
build I've tried to squeeze as much
skill power as possible out of this
build so if you're feeling a little
squishy you can certainly change a few
of the skill power olds over to health
without affecting your damage output too
much the build in front of you right now
consists of four piece technicians an
inventive backpack and a nimble holster
the inventive backpack grants a 15%
increase in skill power while at full
health this is a huge boost in skill
power but if you require a little bit
more survivability in combat switch it
out for the relentless backpack this
will return a percentage of the damage
dealt by your skills as health the
nimble holster will help with health
replenishment provided that you play the
game as it was originally intended as a
cover to cover shooter this is a weaker
option for the belt and should be
changed out when you come across better
gear but it still comes in very useful
skill haste has been rolled onto the
chest gloves and holster skill power
onto the mask kneepads and backpack
enemy armor damage mask and knee pads
and ammo capacity has been rolled onto
the chest and backpack on top of the
skill hast the gloves also assist in
getting more damage out of your weapon
with the assault rifle damage and
critical hit chance another variation to
this build could be full piece
technicians vigorous chest and inventive
backpack this would be run with overdose
first-aid as one of your skills allowing
you a decent overheal ensuring that your
inventive backpack is being propped more
often and making a quite a handy build
and team player but this would mean
you're only running with one damage
skill if you have the ninja buck
messenger bag you can run with three
piece tactician
plus two other set pieces to gain a
further two and three set bonus in this
example I'm using two piece fire crest
this makes it all about the flame turret
with the Seekers or sticky bomb as the
secondary skill in a later video I'll go
a little further and dip this build
focusing more around the flame turret
and burn damage and how this can be one
of the easiest most useful PvE builds
that can be used in the in-game content
being a skill powerbuilt you wouldn't
think that the weapons and the talents
would be very important but this is
where you can really optimize the skill
power build as I said in the last video
I'm a big fan of the high rate of fire
weapons like the lightweight m4 and
isn't geez like the mp5 in this
situation I'd recommend going with a
primary with a little bit more range
than an SMG like an assault rifle
because if all is going well you'll be
staying back from the fighting here I'm
using the lightweight IAM for with the
attributes talented competent and
determined talented killing a target
with this weapon increases skill power
by 15% for 20 seconds competent weapon
damage is increased by 10% for 15
seconds after using a skill and as a
skill power built this will be prompt
quite often increasing your chance of
propping talented determined killing a
target reduces all skill cooldowns by
7.5% because of the stat requirements
you'll need to have this rolled into the
third slot of the weapon the free slot
determined will help you reduce not just
your school cooldowns but also your
signature skills so if you were running
recovery link of which I highly
recommend if you're running solo you'll
be able to get this back in about 10
kills or so also the kills don't need to
come from your weapon that your skill
kills count - this is one of my favorite
talents in the game but you may choose
to swap it out for another attribute
like destructive for example if you're
wanting to get a bit more damage from
your weapon with the secondary weapon as
per usual with my PvE builds I've gone
for a marksman rifle just to offer a bit
more range when needed I'd recommend
going with similar talents but with
predatory and third slots to help with
replenishing health another option
you'll see around when running a skill
power builds is to go to a low
wheelchair and buy weapons or craft them
with the talents you want the advantage
to this is that the requirement to
unlock each talent is lower based on the
lower gear score the only reason I'm not
really a huge fan of this is you don't
quite get the same damage out of your
weapon so propping things like talented
becomes a lot more difficult but this is
still a very viable option when running
a skill build
in this example I'm using the active
sensor turret and cluster seeker mines
I'm guessing us feeling a little lazy
that day with these two skills you can
just pop them down and they do the rest
instead of the turret you could use the
bfz sticky bomb if you like firing
explosive projectiles that do massive
damage you'll have fun with these though
another advantage to the turret is that
it'll help you gain your tactician marks
note this doesn't happen with the flame
turret turret all sticky bomb the
principles are the same
your skills are your main damage dealing
options
the talents I'm running are critical
save this will help you survive certain
situations more often than you may think
I use this in most builds tech support
to keep your turret up for longer death
by proxy you can prop this a lot
taking our enemy turrets and support
stations will provide a large buff to
skill power and chain reaction it's
quite often that you'll be damaging
multiple enemies when using seekers and
sticky bombs however if you're running
sticky bomb rather than a turret I
change our tech support for demolition
expert to help you stack the damage from
one skill to the next if you're running
a flame turret change our death by proxy
for wild fire to help spread the burn to
other targets
gear mod yuan a mixture of electronics
with skill hey store electronics with
skill power depending on the pieces
you're running you may need to have one
firearms mod to unlock your weapon
talents as far as the skill power to
skill haste ratio goes it depends on
your current overall skill haste the
maximum skill haste you can have is 50%
so anything over this is wasted get your
skill haste or as close to 50% as
possible and put the rest into skill
power be aware of skills like the mo
cache support station this adds 15
percent skill haste so if you are
running a support station build your
skill house shouldn't be above 35% you
can check your total skill haste plus a
large number of other things through the
character tab performance mods out of
youth damage dealing skills pick your
favorite this is the skill you'll be
further amplifying if it's your turret
turret damaged sticky bomb adds sticky
bomb damage in this example I'm using
seeker mind damage
as stated earlier sit back and let your
skills do and take the damage switch up
your skills depending on the mission if
you're having trouble with Russia's
running up to you and bursting you down
with shotguns or beating you with golf
clubs switch over to the flame turret it
can be hard in the heat of battle
but remember what weapon and ability
talents you have to increase your skill
damage finish off enemies with your
primary and remember to stack your
technicians bonus shoot down any turrets
and support stations and keep yourself
at full health where possible you're
squishy with this build but you can more
than make up for it with your damage
with this build you'll have success
soloing through challenging with ease
and even legendary missions the tricks
to legendary missions is knowing them
inside and out it's unlikely you'll
breeze through them without dying first
try but give them a few gos and you'll
start to remember the NPC types and
spawns these NPCs are tough but if you
can master these missions a lot of the
other content becomes a lot easier I've
also had a bit of success running
through resistance running up to wave 15
wasn't a problem but found greater
efficiency in opening the reward chest
three times by wave 10 and restarting
the NPC's started getting a little bit
tricky after that this is a good bill to
begin your farming for classified pieces
because this is a beginner's guide video
I haven't included any exotic gear apart
from the ninja bike messenger bag if you
manage to get a hold of the Barretts
bulletproof vest this is a great
addition to the build it'll give you a
further 10% increase of skill power on
the first skill you use skill power
builds can be a lot of fun and open a
lot more of the difficult content but
their lack of focus on survivability can
make them a little more tricky for the
newer player when things go wrong where
you get rushed down you do need to be
able to react quickly or you'll get
taken down fast play around with this
build and remember to adapt it to your
style of play hopefully this has given
you some good pointers or at least a
place to start
any further questions let me know next
we'll be covering the basic DPS build
and after that we'll have covered the
three most common build types that were
mentioned in part 1 so what videos would
you like to see next best farming
options for things like division tech or
Phoenix credits to help optimize your
builds more ninja bike builds maybe or
how to farm the dark zone solo if you
have any requests please mention them in
the comments and if the sound has
already mentioned to throw a thumbs up
otherwise thank you again for watching
this video and I'll see you in the next
Cheers
you
[Music]